so when you talked about the knicks
earlier um and how phil because
everyone's ruined it
phil was as great of a coach as he was
was probably one of the worst basketball
people but it's because basketball is in
this hot seat mode so if we not winning
and he on the hot seat he'd think oh i
got to shift it and i got to do this and
it's like goofy no he wasn't you you
ain't like
when you go to the knicks
melo's there
you got a great young nucleus yourself
j.r smith um yeah he just took too long
took too long to win man
amari had signed in what 2010 so by the
time you got because amari that first
year with the knicks really had like a
mvp type season
but then i think after that the injuries
kind of caught up to him
um but do you think that that's what
happened with the knicks like had you
guys stuck around and jailed a little
bit longer
like i felt like
when we
after we went to this to the second
round and lost to indy which we
shouldn't have lost that i feel like
i keep my comments to myself on that
well that's that's what that's the uh
paul george roy hebert lance stephenson
team yeah
keep my comments myself don't keep it
considered one we should have won
how many games how many games did that
series go six six okay should have won
and coming off of that
i'll never forget working out doing all
this other stuff and we getting ready to
report back
novak gets traded
and i'm
like
what the [ __ ]
what once novak got traded it was just
like what are we doing like
why do y'all continue to
like it's like it just seemed like we're
just doing stuff to our team to just
just to do it yeah like because novak
was like i didn't knock down shooter
good role player but it was perfect for
our ball club right like a perfect fit
yeah i could drive right whenever i want
because nobody's going to help off
nobody right i'm going to dunk this
anybody got an issue with it like
bring your man over here novak that
counts for three you need to count by
two account by three yeah if that's how
i pick your poison but we all knew each
other we had a vibe of energy together
and then it was like yeah nobody's gone
uh meet andre bonyani and it was like
now we and we got drea just in an
uncomfortable position because he's like
if he don't jail now it's like
why we trade for you you know what i'm
saying so now it's like a weird energy
on him also today it's really because we
just miss our dog also too barnyani was
like in a weird position too because
that was like if he if it didn't work
for him there he's definitely a bust
like [ __ ] you know what i mean and then
he was you know saying nervous with the
injury stuff it just it was just a lot
happening that it was just like bro we
had a nice thing going and i understand
why i got tampered with but
who am i bro